oh say can you see by the dawn's early
light what so proudly the twilight's
last gleaming whose broad stripes and
bright stars
[Music]
or the ramparts we watch'd were so
gallantly streaming and the Rockets red
glare the bombs bursting in air gave
proof through the night that our flag
was still there oh say does that
star-spangled banner
or the land of the free and the home
[Music]
Hey
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
please be seated
ladies and gentlemen please welcome a
EEI President Robert doar
good evening everyone I'm Robert doar
president of AEI and on behalf of our
Chairman dan dan yellow and the entire
AI community I welcome you to our annual
dinner we're so glad you could join us
this evening when we have the privilege
of celebrating two great Americans
irving kristol
and ambassador nikki Haley
now I I have to say I begin tonight
remembering the best mass I ever
attended it was the one where Monsignor
Divini of st. Charles Borromeo on Sydney
place in Brooklyn said I'm going to keep
this homily short today because there's
a game on TV I want to see and those of
you those of you who have been with us
before know that it has been our
practice in the past at this point in
the program to invite Bill Kristol up to
say a few words about urban crystal the
Irving Kristol award and to extend
greetings from his mother the Himmelfarb
and their family but Bea and bill could
not be here tonight though they still
send warm greetings and good wishes to
all of us and to ambassador Haley and I
know we send the same to them speaking
of Bill reminds me of the story all
newcomers to AEI are told early in their
tenure it's kind of a rite of passage
and it's an important story when we hold
close in our hearts and it goes like
this in all the years there was only one
time when Urban crystal and bill kristol
appeared together on a panel at a yacht
father and son were seated on the stage
with a moderator between them and the
moderator lobbed questions to each of
them one to Irving one to bill about
their respective careers and views on
our country and all was going fine until
as the final question the moderator
asked bill what was the best advice you
ever got and Bill was stumped he didn't
know what to say so much advice which
fits bit of knowledge to pick what was
the best advice and then Irving leaned
in his microphone and said honor thy
father
so during my first few months as
president of AEI earrings words about
people in my position has provided a
kind of comfort a think tank president
said Irving is someone who speaks with
authority about subjects in which he has
no particular competence now thankfully
at AEI I am surrounded by scholars who
have exceptional competence when it
comes to confronting our nation's
greatest challenges and many of them are
here tonight and I want to start by
recognizing and thanking AI scholars who
are the heart and soul of our
institution many of these scholars have
decades of experience on the front lines
of public policy shaping it implementing
it seeing how good public policy can
lift people up and how bad policy can
tear them down and of course Irving
Kristol had a very different kind of
frontline experience he described his
time in the army during World War two as
deeply formative when he joined he was a
socialist his regiment was full of tough
guys from the southside of Chicago and
by the end of his time with these
competitive less than angelic
individualist he was pretty sure
socialism would never work in America
that wouldn't be the last time
Irving was mugged by reality in the half
century that followed Irving went on to
become one of the greatest scholars of
his generation he shaped public debate
and defined the core values that we
still fight for every day writing about
everything from welfare and religion to
Joseph McCarthy and the sexual
revolution he never lost his dedication
to his country and its promise his
political principles live on in AE eyes
work including economic freedom American
global leadership an equality of
opportunity equality of opportunity not
equality of outcome this idea was
crystallized for me when I first read
her Vings essay what is a
neoconservative
and he brought the point
for me at an AI gathering some years
later when he said he especially did not
like equality in sports now is the great
sports fan myself I love that reference
to sports and for those Nationals fans
here tonight it must have some
significance
what would having your team play in the
World Series mean if all outcomes were
equal why would anyone strive to do
great things about it without a chance
for great success and why should we deny
the fruits of success to people who have
earned them one of my Brooklyn
schoolteachers once described to me the
joy he felt on the night in 1938 when
Max Schmeling the German boxer who had
been a favorite of Hitler and a darling
of the Nazi Party came to New York to
fight Joe Louis Louis
the heavyweight from Alabama known as
the brown bomber knocked him out in less
than three minutes given a chance for a
fair fight
Lewis proved himself now there is an
example of equal opportunity leading to
great unequal results
Irving also had a deep understanding of
the connection between politics and the
human good he hoped that one day we
would be able to bring our public and
private lives back together into what he
called a congenial relationship where
our politics supported family religion
and community life a great admiration
for Irving's legacy on this front is one
reason why we've created the new social
cultural and constitutional studies
division at AEI
I'm confident that herbing loved America
so deeply would be proud of our efforts
to invigorate this component of AE ice
work it's also why we brought the great
policy journal national affairs which I
know will continue to be the
intellectual heir to Irving's public
interest in Irving's lessons in foreign
policy also inform us today while Pete
Seeger was singing about flowers
Irving was asking where of all the
gunboats gone he was never afraid to
promote his own pragmatic sense of
Affairs including a firm commitment to
American allies and a dedication to
American global leadership that's why he
often lamented what he called the
ironies of Neo isolationism and the
mistakes of those who would see America
withdraw from the world stage in Irving
mind America's role in the world
required a careful balancing of prudence
and restraint with a willingness to act
even unilaterally when necessary and he
thought these concerns about America's
spirit and America's role in the world
were connected if the United States is
to gain the respect of world opinion
Irving Road in 1975 it first has to
demonstrate that it respects itself its
own institutions its own way of life the
political and social philosophy that is
the basis of its institutions and its
way of life to persuade the world we
have to show the world that we love our
country that line of thinking helps us
see why our honoree tonight
ambassador nikki Haley is an ideal
person to receive the Irving Kristol
award during her time at the United
Nations ambassador Haley embodied this
idea that a constructive role for
America in the world begins with
self-respect
she is unafraid to stand up for American
ideals and American interests and she
knows how closely connected the two
always are it was so refreshing and
reassuring to hear her press this point
at the UN and I trust she will continue
to be a powerful advocate for what is
best about our country in the years to
come and like Irving Kristol ambassador
Haley has always been a staunch defender
of religious freedom and the role of
faith at home and abroad one of
America's greatest Grace's is its
welcoming of religious minorities an
appreciation for the role of faith in an
individual's life and ambassador Haley's
own history proves that her parents
immigrated to America from Amma star
India favorite teachers her father at a
historically black college and her
mother in the local public school
in their new home in Bamberg South
Carolina to him Haley family thrived
there and her success proves that
diverse practices and perspectives only
enrich American public life regardless
of whether you're Christians Sikh Jewish
or Muslim a person of any faith or of
none American life is open to you if you
live by our laws contribute to our
society and bring the best of your
traditions to the work of building our
country you will be an American
ambassador Haley's story affirms that
American ethos to follow her career is
to see the great example she is set at
home and around the world
she has been an eloquent and powerful
advocate for America on the world stage
as ambassador to the United Nations an
impassioned defender of limited
government as governor of South Carolina
and a powerful voice of moral clarity in
our national political climate whether
its vulnerable people in her home state
or persecuted two-sentence dissidents in
China or Russia nikki Haley has provided
a sympathetic ear and a strong voice and
if Irving could be here tonight he might
offer one final reminder for all of us
he wrote that America is unique among
nations and being founded not on race
not on kinship not on language not on
religion but on political values the
essence of being an American is not your
party class or creed not your race or
your religion but rather your
willingness to share in a common set of
principles ambassador Haley a daughter
of South Carolina is the perfect
exemplar Irving would be proud of anyone
in public life who has set such an
example of courage decency and
patriotism our Irving Kristol award is
given annually to recognize an
individual's intellectual and practical
contributions to government policy
social welfare or political
understanding but it's all too rare to
find someone like nikki Haley who's done
so much in all three fields so please
join me in applauding ambassador Haley
as we honor her
[Applause]
[Music]
so much
thank you Robert congratulations on
taking leadership of this amazing
institution I want to thank you
your predecessor Arthur Brooks and the
entire AEI family for honoring me with
this award it's humbling to stand at
this podium tonight this is the same
dinner where Alan Greenspan warned of
irrational exuberance this is the same
dinner where Charles Krauthammer
described an American foreign policy for
a unipolar world and of course it's the
dinner where AEI interns eat for free
that's so great and I really want to
thank all of you for showing up tonight
a I had the wisdom to schedule this
dinner on the same night as Game six of
the World Series they really wanted to
test how many of you were dedicated to
public policy I will forgive those of
you who decide to check your phones for
the score like my husband over here it's
a tremendous honor to receive an award
named for the great curving crystal who
did so much to strengthen the
intellectual foundations that led to
American victory in the Cold War and
freedom for hundreds of millions of
people for most of the past 15 years I
have lived and worked where AEE eyes
ideas are tested in practice in South
Carolina we led the way on opening
markets reducing regulations reforming
education and moving people from welfare
to work from those of us for those of us
engaged in conservative Public Policy
AEI is a trusted source you don't have
to agree with all of its ideas but you
can be sure they are all deeply rooted
in America's values you can have
confidence they exist to preserve what
President Lincoln called the last best
hope of Earth I want to start by saying
I am optimistic about America's future I
know that for those who spend too much
time on Twitter it may at times look
like it's all over for the American
experiment depending on which cable
network you prefer there is a sense that
things are coming off the rails in
America today we have our problems
there's no denying that but America has
survived a revolution a foreign invasion
a civil war a Great Depression the
largest war in world history and social
unrest
of a dozen different
stripes and we've come out stronger
after every test we are a truly
exceptional nation one reason things may
seem dark especially on social media and
cable news is that we have lots of
people who are attempting to reject the
very things that set America apart this
is a real problem and it's one we should
strongly resist our history is being
attacked as a lie influential voices on
the Left claim America was founded not
in freedom but in oppression the idea
that we must be in control of our
borders is dismissed as uncaring bigotry
some are attempting to redefine American
citizenship itself Ronald Reagan once
asked Americans to choose between being
citizens or subjects it was the 60s
government and liberalism were on the
march the question fit the times today
we face a different choice it is a
choice between citizenship and
victimhood our politics is becoming a
contest over who's got the biggest
grievance who's getting the short end of
the stick who's being taken advantage of
by rigged system back then Reagan
pointed to big government as the enemy
and he was right today Americans
increasingly see each other as the enemy
and that's not right too many regard
those who disagree with them not simply
as wrong but as evil but it's hard to
have government by the people and for
the people if we regard each other is
unworthy of even having a conversation
with you see this a lot on college
campuses but you even see it at
restaurants these days I can't believe
I'm saying this but sometimes it even
makes me miss what passes for moral
Claire
at the United Nations
my distinguished predecessor and an AE I
alumna Jean Kirkpatrick said her
experience at the UN left her quote in
every way a sadder and wiser woman about
the world unquote while I rarely
disagree with the with ambassador Corps
Patrick we do partially differ on this
my time at the UN certainly made me
wiser about the world and sadder about
parts of it but it also made me more
grateful about our country at the UN I
worked alongside the ambassadors of
dictators and strongmen I traveled to
places most Americans will never go and
I saw things most Americans will never
see what I saw cut through the loud and
polarizing voices in our country
I saw what sets America apart what we
must protect and preserve when you've
heard a South Sudanese refugee woman
tell you about watching soldiers throw
her baby into a fire when you've seen
Venezuelan families walk for hours in
the Blazing Sun to receive the one meal
they might have that day when you've
negotiated with representatives of a
Chinese regime that is building a
surveillance state that would horrify
Orwell when you've seen and done these
things you see just how profound the
gifts are that we have received as
Americans and they're not just for
Americans when the cameras were off at
the UN ambassadors from all parts of the
world made it clear to me that they envy
our ability to live and speak freely
they admire our principles and they
depend on us to lead the world in
accordance with our values at times this
is a much harder case to make among
Americans than among nations we are too
caught up in our differences where their
socio-economic racial or religious these
differences increasingly
define our politics to a certain extent
they should we are very different people
and there are important differences
between the political parties we
shouldn't gloss over those differences
we should debate them vigorously but
when we retreat into identity and
grievance politics we make the choice
for victimhood over citizenship by
constantly blaming others we reject
personal responsibility for ourselves
our families in our communities
the choice of victimhood takes us
further away from our exceptionalism but
we can still be optimistic about our
future as an exceptional nation and
here's why 93 years ago on the hundred
and fiftieth anniversary of the signing
of the Declaration of Independence
President Calvin Coolidge President
Calvin Coolidge said quote amid all the
clash of conflicting interests amid all
the welter of partisan politics every
American can turn for solace in
consolation to the Declaration of
Independence and the Constitution of the
United States that statement is just as
fitting today equality before the law
freedom inalienable rights these are not
abstractions
they are inheritance as human beings the
Declaration of Independence outline them
the Constitution established them as a
system of government it is these sacred
principles that make me optimistic they
anchor our nation and they show us the
way forward for instance our immigration
system is truly broken it is no longer
controlled by the rule of law it doesn't
acknowledge much less emphasize the
values that make us Americans the
American people are justifiably
concerned
both the security of our borders and by
America's place as a home for those with
the dream and drive to breathe free
people from all over the world are drawn
to the United States by our
exceptionalism our freedom our
opportunity in our belief in human
dignity my parents were among them they
came from India to rural South Carolina
in the 1960s my mother my mother wore a
sari my father wore a turban he still
does to this day we were different we
stood out and my family felt the pain of
being judged by our difference many
Americans had felt this pain many have
felt much worse but my parents refused
to let it define them they chose
citizenship over victimhood they came to
the United States legally they respected
the right of the American people to
protect their sovereignty to be the ones
who decide who can join us and in return
America welcomed them immigration is a
source of American strength when it is
conducted in accordance with our
principles but it must be a two-way
street
we welcome immigrants who come to
America in accordance with the rule of
law and we must call upon those
immigrants to embrace our values and
respect our laws in order to become
Americans American leadership in the
world is also challenged by some today
to remain strong they say America must
give up its advocacy of freedom and
human dignity abroad this represents a
failure of memory a world without United
States leadership does not mean a world
in which our values and interests
peacefully coexist with other countries
if it meant countries could live
peacefully pursuing their interests
there would be more to recommend the
United States retreating from the world
instead it means a world with Chinese
values devoted to Chinese interests it
means a world with Russian values
devoted to Russian interests it means a
world in which radical Islam runs
rampant that is a dark place for
American values and a dangerous place
for American security it would be nicer
and cheaper if American leadership was
not needed to protect our values and our
interests sadly that's not the world we
live in if you don't believe me I invite
you to spend a day in the United Nations
Security Council some of its most
powerful members not only don't share
American values they actively work to
defeat them we faced a choice either
sacrifice our values in an attempt to
win friends at the UN or defend our
values and fight some fights virtually
alone freedom and human dignity aren't
just the right values to promote they
are our most powerful foreign policy
tools which is why we fought for them we
called out Russia for its violations of
Ukraine's sovereignty we sanctioned the
North Korean regime for representing a
unique evil in the world a dictatorship
that is starving its own people to
finance the creation of nuclear weapons
and on Israel after a heartbreaking
betrayal by the previous administration
we once again embraced our friend and
Ally
at the UN Israel is the clearest example
of this worldwide clash of values the
only fully democratic country in the
Middle East is routinely demonized as an
oppressor the only country in the region
that represents religious freedom gender
equality and gay rights is singled out
for abuse in the tragically mislaid UN
Human Rights Council if America does not
lead the way in stopping this nonsense
no one else will here at home the
presidential election season is upon us
with that comes the inevitable running
to the partisan barricades and that's
okay
electing a president is serious business
the two sides have very different
visions for our country we deserve a
spirited campaign to debate those
differences but here again respect for
the Constitution should guide us
president Trump is a disrupter that
makes some people very happy and it
makes some people very mad but if we are
a country that lives by the rule of law
we must all accept that we have one
president at a time and that president
attained his office by the choice of the
American people
when I was in the administration I
served alongside colleagues who believe
that the best thing to do for America
was to undermine and obstruct the
president some wrote about it
anonymously in the New York Times others
just did it they sincerely believed they
were doing the right thing I sincerely
believed they weren't the president was
the choice of the people in accordance
with our founding chart Charter no
policy disagreement with him no matter
how heartfelt justifies undermining the
lawful authority that is vested in his
office by the Constitution for those who
don't like the president they are free
to protest him and many do but if you
serve in the administration you are not
free to push your personal agenda what's
at stake is not president Trump's
policies what's at stake is the
Constitution we're in
we are a nation with a history borders
and common language we are also the
first nation devoted to a higher good
our beliefs are what make us Americans
our Constitution is what allows this
great experiment in democracy to survive
and thrive
AEI gets this you are working to restore
respect for the Constitution in American
life congratulations on your new
research division for social cultural
and constitutional studies
[Applause]
another reason I'm optimistic is because
I've been spending time with high school
and college students most often they
face hostility on their campuses because
of their conservative views but they are
undaunted they want to be leaders
specifically American leaders they
appreciate the things that make America
exceptional the more time I spend with
these young people the more confident I
am about our future these young
Americans are not complacent far from it
they understand that our ability to
speak freely to debate to worship and
determine our own destinies these are
things to be grateful for and preserve
it was 1862 when Abraham Lincoln called
America the last best hope of Earth our
country was more deeply divided than
ever before or since it was a time of
war for the country and a time of
political peril for Lincoln still he
showed confidence in America's future in
his message Lincoln asked repeatedly can
we do better he answers his own question
by reminding his country men and women
of America's higher purpose and greater
gifts our exceptionalism
I can't match the wisdom and eloquence
of Lincoln but like him I believe in the
American people's ability to find our
way through any challenge by honoring
the beliefs that define us there will
always be work to do to be a more
perfect union but we will always do
better if we acknowledge the truth that
the world already knows about us even on
our worst days we are blessed to be
Americans
thank you very much
god bless thank